oh mann eigentlich wollte die
bundesregierung eine million
elektroautos bis 2020 doch bisher
passiert ist nichts beziehungsweise so
gut wie nichts gestern war mein
elektro-smart übrigens thema bei focus
online weil das land berlin noch einen
drauf setzte reichweitenbeschränkung
durchlade zeitbeschränkung die neueste
methode um interessenten für die
elektromobilität abzuschrecken jetzt in
klicks um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen
das ist wirklich verrückt da macht man
sich beim kauf eines elektrofahrzeugs
eine menge gedanken und zwar vor allem
um ein thema wie groß ist die reichweite
eines elektroautos beim einem
gebrauchten smart electric drive ist mit
bis zu 150 kilometern
die schon ganz ordentlich vor allem für
den stadtverkehr hier in berlin ist sie
perfekt alle paar tage laden das passt
ja wenn man das fahrzeug verladen könnte
das geht nämlich in berlin nicht
zumindest nicht mit meinem elektro-smart
und vielen vielen anderen
elektrofahrzeugen auch nicht die
betreiber des öffentlichen ladennetzes
stammen nämlich aus absurdistan und
haben sich etwas ganz besonderes
ausgedacht um die elektro autofahrer zu
ärgern wenn die batterien heute schon
einige hundert kilometer reichweite
bieten dann beschränken wir doch die
reichweite mit einer ladezeit begrenzung
wort ja man glaubt es kaum tatsächlich
sind die betreiber auf diese absurde
idee gekommen und es ist überhaupt nicht
erklärbar an der überbuchung der
ladesäulen kann es nicht liegen die sind
nämlich fast alle immer frei was man
hier auf der karte an den bunten
blättern sieht höchstens falschparken
dem benziner machen sich hier breit und
bei bimobil scheint so niemand richtig
einen plan zu haben mir wurde
geschrieben dass die meisten
elektroautos heute schneller laden
könnten und so die vier stunden
ausreichen würden
oh mann das ist wirklich ziemlich falsch
also erstens die meisten ladesäulen von
b e mobil laden mit maximal elf
kilowattstunden sprich sie können gar
nicht schnell laden ein tesla mit einer
batteriekapazität von 85 kilowattstunden
würde hier rund acht stunden brauchen
selbst wenn er schnell laden könnte an
den meisten sollen geht es eben nicht
und zweitens immer mehr elektrofahrzeuge
haben solche immer größere batterien und
können deshalb einfach nicht in vier
stunden voll geladen werden wie
immobilien wollte das missverständnis
aufklären und rief mich an
da hätten wir wohl etwas aneinander
vorbei geredet meinte die nette dame am
anderen ende der leitung und achtung
jetzt kommt s isch hat sich denn da
jemand gedanken drüber gemacht die
antwort aus dem gedächtnis ja da würde
ich sie schon von ausgehen ich da
zweifel ich aber dran tatsächlich
scheint niemand darüber nachgedacht zu
haben und das ist eine katastrophe in
unserer bundeshauptstadt arbeitet
man so gegen die elektromobilität und
gegen eine stadt mit sauberer luft und
auch an anderer stelle wird einfach
nichts getan
die durch bundesgesetz möglichen
ausnahmen die benutzung der busspuren
freies parken und so weiter für
elektroautos in berlin gibt es nichts
rein gar nichts
es ist so peinlich und dabei und jetzt
möchte ich mal kurz erklären warum ich
hier kommentiere ist es für den
klimawandel und um ihn zu stoppen
unabdingbar dass wir so schnell wie
möglich auf saubere antriebe wechseln
wissenschaftlich tausendfach gefordert
müssen wir runter von fossilen energien
und es gibt keinen außer ein paar
verteilten oder vielleicht donald trump
noch die daran zweifeln nur hier in
berlin tut man alles um diese
entwicklung noch irgendwie zu bremsen
das ist wirklich einfach nur unfassbar
peinlich ich hoffe dass die
berichterstattung vielleicht die ein
oder andere schlafmütze in der berliner
senatsverwaltung auf weg frei nach dem
motto guten abend meine damen und herren
guten morgen liebe beamte
falls sich hier etwas tut halte ich euch
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn er kein
video dazu und auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt drückt mir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
mit bald nur noch elektroautos technik
vor technologiesprung sei es richtig mit
noch mehr infos zu ja zu allem was sich
rund um elektromobilität handelt also
viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dahin
bleibt dran